La promesa de que en los próximos 15 años
mejorarían las vidas de miles de millones de persona
sin excluir a nadie.
Esa promesa son los Objetivos de Desarrollo Sostenible...
los ODS.
Ya han pasado tres años;
un quinto de la trayectoria.
El tiempo corre.
Si nos desenfocamos ahora
se hará cada vez más difícil alcanzar esos objetivos.
Hoy voy a darles un pequeño resumen
sobre dónde estamos en este momento,
algunas proyecciones sobre hacia dónde vamos
e ideas sobre cosas que deberíamos hacer de forma diferente.
Los ODS son realmente complicados.
No me esperaba menos de las Naciones Unidas.
(Risas)
¿Cuántos objetivos?
Quizás unos tres, siete o 10 ya previamente establecidos.
No, escojamos un número primo mayor que 10.
Diecisiete objetivos.
Felicito a quienes se lo han memorizado.
Aquí están para el resto de nosotros.
Diecisiete objetivos que incluyen acabar con la pobreza,
crear ciudades inclusivas,
promover la pesca sostenible;
un plan integral para el futuro de nuestro mundo.
Lamentablemente, es un plan sin datos para medirlo.
Entonces, ¿cómo mediremos su progreso?
Pues bien, hoy usaré el Índice de Progreso Social,
que mide la calidad de vida en los países,
que incluye las necesidades básicas para la sobrevivencia:
alimento, agua, vivienda, seguridad...
las bases para el bienestar:
educación, información, salud y bienestar...
y las oportunidades:
derechos, libertades personales, inclusión y acceso a educación superior.
El Índice de Progreso Social no se parece a los ODS,
aunque fundamentalmente mide los mismos conceptos,
y tiene la ventaja de que cuenta con datos.
Tenemos 51 indicadores provenientes de fuentes confiables
para medir estos conceptos.
Y porque es un índice
podemos sumar todos esos indicadores para obtener una calificación total
que nos mostrará cómo vamos en relación con el total de los ODS.
Un pequeño detalle:
el Índice de Progreso Social mide la calidad de vida
y no determina si se puede alcanzar o no
según los recursos limitados del planeta.
Para eso se necesitarán otras herramientas.
Entonces, ¿cómo vamos con los ODS?
Voy a poner los ODS en una escala de cero a 100.
Cero es la peor calificación en cada uno de estos 51 indicadores:
ningún progreso social, cero.
Y 100 es la mínima calificación requerida para alcanzar los ODS.
Queremos llegar a 100 en el 2030.
Ahora, ¿por dónde comenzamos?
Afortunadamente, no desde cero.
En el 2015, la calificación mundial para alcanzar los ODS era 69,1.
Estamos encaminados pero aún nos falta un buen tramo.
Hay que enfatizar que esta predicción mundial,
que se basa en la información de 180 países,
dependerá del tamaño de la población.
Así que China tendrá más peso que Comoros;
India más que Islandia.
Pero podemos verlo en detalle y observar cómo les va a los países.
Actualmente, el país más cercano a la meta de los ODS es Dinamarca.
Y el país con el camino más largo es la República Centroafricana.
El resto se encuentra entre estos dos.
El desafío para los ODS
es trata de movilizar todos estos puntos hasta llegar a 100 para el 2030.
¿Lo lograremos?
Con el Índice de Progreso Social existen datos que abarcan un período de tiempo,
así que podemos tener una idea acerca de la dirección en la que van los países
y crear proyecciones.
Veamos.
Comencemos con Dinamarca, el país que va a la cabeza.
Sí, me alegra decir que este país va en camino a alcanzar los ODS en el 2030.
Quizás no sea una sorpresa, pero me alegra.
Veamos algunos de los países más ricos del mundo...
el G7.
Vemos que Alemania y Japón llegarán o estarán muy cerca.
Pero Canadá, Francia, el Reino Unido e Italia, aún les faltará un buen tramo.
¿Y EE. UU.?
Incluso un poco más.
Esto es preocupante.
Aunque estos son los países más ricos de mundo,
no los más poblados.
Veamos ahora a los países más poblados,
los que tienen el mayor peso para determinar si alcanzaremos los ODS.
Y estos son...
los países con una población de más 100 millones de habitantes,
desde China hasta Etiopía.
Ciertamente EE. UU. y Japón estarían en la lista
pero ya los vimos anteriormente.
Aquí los tienen.
Los países más poblados del mundo; los de mayor peso en los ODS.
El país que mostrará el mayor progreso hacia el alcance de los ODS
es México.
México llegará como a 87,
muy cerca de EE. UU.
pero aún lejos de la meta de los ODS.
Le sigue Rusia.
Luego, China e Indonesia.
Seguido por Brasil... que esperábamos que le fuera mejor.
Filipinas,
y un poco más allá, India, Bangladesh, Pakistán, Nigeria
y Etiopía.
Ninguno de estos países alcanzarán los ODS.
Podemos tomar estas cifras de todos los países del mundo
y crear una predicción mundial
sobre el logro total de los ODS.
Recuerden, en el 2015 partimos de 69,1.
Me alegra poder informar que en los últimos tres años
hemos progresado un poco.
En el 2018 llegamos a 70,5
y si proyectamos que manteniendo este ritmo de progreso hasta el 2010
solo llegaremos a 75,2;
aún muy lejos de nuestra meta.
Si mantenemos la tendencia actual no alcanzaremos los ODS sino en el 2094.
No sé Uds.,
pero ciertamente no quiero esperar tanto.
¿Qué podemos hacer al respecto?
Lo primero es exhortar a los países ricos.
Estos son los países que están más cerca de la meta de los ODS,
tienen muchísimos recursos
pero aun así no los alcanzarán.
Quizás piensan que es como en el pasado
donde las metas de la ONU eran solo para las naciones pobres y no para ellos.
Pues están equivocados.
Los ODS son para todos los países,
y es una vergüenza que estos países ricos no lleguen a la meta.
Todos los países necesitan un plan para implementar los ODS
y ejecutarlo para sus ciudadanos.
Así que G7, otros países ricos...
pónganse las pilas.
Segundo, podemos observar mejor los datos
y ver dónde están las oportunidades para acelerar el progreso
y las tendencias negativas que podemos revertir.
Les voy a hablar de tres áreas.
Un aspecto en donde estamos progresando,
otro en donde deberíamos mejorar
y el último, donde tenemos serios problemas.
Comencemos con las buenas noticias
y quiero hablarles de la nutrición y los cuidados médicos básicos.
Esto abarca el ODS 3 sobre el hambre
y los elementos básicos del ODS 3 sobre salud,
como la mortalidad infantil y materna, enfermedades infecciosas, etc....
Este es un área donde la mayoría de los países ricos han logrado alcanzar.
También vemos, observando los países más poblados,
que los más avanzados también se han acercado bastante.
He aquí los 11 países más poblados
y si miran arriba,
Brasil y Rusia están muy cerca de alcanzar los ODS.
Pero en la base...
Etiopía, Pakistán... aún tienen un largo trayecto.
Aquí estamos en el 2018.
¿Cuál es nuestra trayectoria?
¿A dónde llegaremos en el 2030
manteniendo la trayectoria actual?
Veamos.
Como ven, hay mucho progreso.
Vean a Bangladesh en el medio.
Si Bangladesh mantiene la tasa actual de progreso
podría llegar muy cerca a la meta de ese ODS.
Y Etiopía, en la base, está realizando un gran progreso
en este momento.
Si se mantiene, Etiopía llegará muy lejos.
Si sumamos todos los países del mundo
nuestra proyección nos dará una calificación de 94,5 en el 2030.
Y si países como Filipinas que está avanzando más lentamente,
logra acelerar su progreso,
entonces llegaremos aún más cerca.
Tenemos razones para ser optimistas en cuanto a los ODS 2 y 3.
Pero hay otra área básica de los ODS donde no nos va tan bien:
el ODS 6, sobre el agua y el saneamiento.
Una vez más, es un ODS donde la mayoría de los países ricos
han llegado a la meta.
Y en los países más poblados...
esos 11 países emergentes más grandes,
vemos que algunos, como Rusia y México,
están muy cerca de la meta,
pero Nigeria y otros países aún están muy lejos.
¿Cómo vamos con este objetivo?
¿Qué progreso veremos en los próximos 12 años
basado en la tendencia actual?
Aquí lo tienen...
sí, habrá progreso.
Todos los cuatro países a la cabeza alcanzarán este ODS...
algunos incluso muy pronto.
Pero no es suficiente para mejorar la tasa general de forma significativa.
Para el mundo en su totalidad,
la predicción es una calificación de 85 u 86 en el 2030...
no es suficiente.
Obviamente, estas no son buenas noticias
aunque lo que los datos nos muestran es que podemos hacerlo mucho mejor.
El agua y el saneamiento son problemas resueltos.
Se trata de escalar esa solución para llegar a todos.
Así que si podemos acelerar el progreso en algunos de los países
que están avanzando más lentamente,
como Nigeria, Filipinas, etc....
llegaremos mucho más cerca de la meta.
Creo que el ODS 6 es probablemente el que tiene la mayor oportunidad
de todos los ODS de poder cambiar.
Ese es un área donde nos puede ir mejor.
Finalmente, veamos un área donde tenemos problemas,
como los derechos personales y la inclusión.
Esto cubre una gran gama de ODS.
El ODS 1 sobre el fin de la pobreza, el ODS 5 acerca de la igualdad de género,
el ODS 10 acerca de las desigualdades,
el ODS 11 sobre las ciudades inclusivas
y el ODS 16 sobre la paz y la justicia.
En todos estos ODS hay temas sobre los derechos y la inclusión
que parecieran ser menos inmediatos o urgentes
en comparación al hambre y a las enfermedades,
aunque los derechos y la inclusión son críticos para que nadie sea excluido.
¿Cómo vamos con estos problemas?
Comencemos con los derechos personales.
Voy a mostrarles los países más poblados del 2015.
Aquí están,
y he puesto EE. UU. y Japón de vuelta,
así que son los 13 países más poblados.
Hay una amplia gama de calificaciones.
Con EE. UU. a la cabeza, Japón alcanzando las metas
y China mucho más atrás.
¿Cuál ha sido la dirección de nuestro progreso
en materia de derechos en los últimos 3 años?
Veamos.
Como pueden ver, es desalentador.
La mayoría de los países están estancados o han retrocedido,
y países como Brasil, India, China y Bangladesh
han experimentado reducciones importantes.
Esto es preocupante.
Veamos la inclusión.
La inclusión se trata de cosas
como la violencia y la discriminación contra las minorías,
la igualdad de géneros, la inclusión de los LGBT, etc....
Podemos ver que las calificaciones para estos países son generalmente bajas.
Todos los países, ya sean ricos o pobres, luchan por igual
para crear una sociedad más inclusiva.
Pero ¿cuál es la dirección de la trayectoria?
¿Estamos creando países más inclusivos?
Veamos... el progreso hasta el 2018.
Nuevamente, el mundo se mueve en sentido contrario:
la mayoría estancados,
muchos países retrocediendo...
Bangladesh está retrocediendo...
aunque también dos de los países que estaban avanzando...
Brasil y EE. UU.
han retrocedido de forma significativa
en los últimos tres años.
Sumemos para ver el mundo en su totalidad.
En materia de los derechos personales en todo el mundo
lo que se proyecta es una disminución en la calificación
hasta llegar a 60,
y en cuanto a inclusión, disminuye a 42.
Claro que estas cosas pueden cambiar rápidamente
con la promulgación de derechos y los cambios en las leyes, en actitudes,
pero tenemos que aceptar que bajo la tendencia actual
quizás sea el aspecto más preocupante de los ODS.
¿Los deprimí?
(Risas)
Espero que no, porque lo que vemos
es que hay progreso en muchos lugares
y tenemos oportunidades para acelerarlo.
Vivimos en una época que está mucho más cerca
de lograr que nadie tenga que morir de hambre, o por malaria o diarrea.
Si enfocamos nuestros esfuerzos, movilizamos los recursos
y motivamos la voluntad política,
el cambio es posible.
Al enfocarnos en los ODS más básicos y alcanzables
no olvidemos que se trata de todo el paquete.
Las metas son un conjunto de indicadores y objetivos difíciles de manejar,
aunque también incluye los desafíos que enfrenta nuestro mundo.
Que los ODS enfoquen su atención
en la crisis existente en materia de derechos personales e inclusión
es algo positivo.
Si lo olvidamos,
si solo nos concentramos en los ODS que podemos alcanzar,
si escogemos solo los ODS más fáciles,
no estaremos cumpliendo con el verdadero propósito de los ODS,
no llegaremos a las metas
y habremos fallado en cumplir nuestra promesa con los ODS.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)